so I'm gonna save you guys the trouble
because I know most of the comments are
gonna say Justine did you really just
make an entire video about unboxing a
pair of ear pods yeah and this isn't the
first time I've done something that sort
I'm sure you guys are very familiar with
these by now this has pretty much been
my headphones of choice since I got
these a few years ago which is kind of
crazy because when I first got them they
really didn't fit in my ear that wasn't
sure how I felt about them but now I
honestly can't leave home without them
obviously there are headphones out there
that have a much better sound quality
but for what these are the ease of use
and the portability and how quick they
charge and I feel like they're always
with me I have lost them several times
but I've always found them but in this
specific video these air bags that cost
about 399 dollars and you would be right
by saying Justin are you crazy why would
you do that or you have to be crazy I'm
also using the excuse that I bought this
as a gift for myself for hitting five
million subscribers so thank you guys so
much I didn't make a video about it
because I don't really even know what to
say other than thank you maybe I'll
think of something fun and cool to do in
another video but for now I haven't
thought of that yet so let me know if
you have any suggestions but now we're
just gonna go ahead and unbox these so
here's the air pods from the outside
they look just like any other normal air
pods but they're not these are color
wear ear pods if you guys aren't
familiar with color air they make really
cool custom products you guys remember I
know I get a lot of questions about this
my NES which has this really cool custom
vintage look to it and that is also by
color wear so let's unbox these I'm so
excited I saw them go on sale my job is
going crazy a bunch of you guys tweeted
me this and such a scene you have to get
this and they said you're right I do
let's open oh I see it I see them I see
them Wow
Oh a little note body sweats and oils
can range from neutral to moderately
acidic sweating oils or more acidic
color we're recommends cleaning your air
pods after you look at your color clean
look they give you a little a little
sterile alcohol prep pad okay here they
are so as you can see it is vintage
Apple themed and love it they even put
this back on that's so so kind of you
guys
so these bridges are even raised so we
were to ask me Justine are these worth
four hundred dollars I would well I'd
give you two answers one if you have the
extra cash that you're looking to spend
on something like this then yeah it is
and the reason that I do say yes is
because the quality of this is really
incredible it gets not just a simple
skin this is custom painted everything
is so perfect so in that aspect yes you
are definitely paying for a quality
piece of work to be honest with you I
feel like this is something that one day
down the line many many years later when
there's an eye Justine Museum of all of
my Apple products these will be sitting
there in a glass case with a screen shot
of this video and we like remember when
Justine a box or dollar earplugs here
they are actually I thought would be
really fun to do sort of like a display
or something where you guys can come
meet me hang out and look at some of my
Apple products that's weird but I think
I'm into so let me know if that's
something that you're into maybe that's
what I could do for my 5 million
subscriber party she's away I just want
to show you guys this because a lot of
you did send me links to this and said
Justine you gotta get these you have to
check them out I want to see what they
look like
well here's what they look like so like
I said the attention to detail is what
sets these apart from like anything all
their products everything is just
perfectly lined up so that's if they
feel like in my ears even repainted the
LME are on them it does have a different
kind of texture than the normal sort of
very smooth plastic but they feel pretty
normal like it doesn't feel that
different that doesn't feel exactly the
same a little more of a textured feel on
the website they give you many different
options of things that you can customize
so we're example the air pods you can
customize the case you've customized
each air pod a different color and
there's two ways to you guys can do it
so you could basically send them a
brand-new pair of air pods or you can
buy the brand new air pods from them
directly again this isn't sponsored but
I thought these are really cool and I
wanted to share it with you especially
if you are anything Kitsch Apple
collector or if you just have $399 that
you were really looking to spend you
could buy these well thank you guys for
watching I just wanted to thank you
again so much for being here for so many
years
and for subscribing I know a lot of you
guys have been here from the beginning
so it's really great to see you see you
out the comments see you out in the real
world and if you aren't already
subscribed be sure to do so and also hit
the bell so you guys will know when I
post a new video let me know if you guys
have any other suggestions for things
you'd like to see me make videos on
because a lot of times some of the
things that I'm making videos about you
guys are tweeting them to me and I'm
seeing it and then I'm crazy and buying
them case in point
I'll see you guys in my next video bye
[Music]